the creatures in The Witcher might have
come from myths and legends but they
don't look exactly like their
traditional counterparts they don't
quite act like them either these are the
stories that inspired some of the
witcher's most fearsome beasts Netflix
is the witcher opens with a swampy duel
between Geralt of Rivia and the key
Kimura a hulking spider-like creature
with an unsettling human head while
Geralt makes quick work of the beasts
that Kiki Mora ends up getting the last
laugh
despite the Kiki Morris ferocity no one
is willing to pay Geralt for its corpse
making all his effort futile while the
Kiki Mora battle makes for a great
opening set-piece the witcher's version
of the creature both in the series and
in the games is a very liberal take on
the Kiki more a legend in Slavic
mythology a Kiki Mora is a house spirit
that sneaks into your home via your
keyhole in order to deliver bad news
once a Kiki Mora settles in it can also
cause nightmares sleep paralysis and
nighttime calamities like dying cattle
and spoiled food they'll never look
directly at a Kiki Mora either
do so and you might die instead of a
multi-legged monstrosity a Kiki Mora
typically looks like a mix between an
old woman and a bird complete with a
beak and chicken legs and a head scarf
wrapped around her stringy hair I like
Geralt you typically don't kill them
with a sword either just leave some food
behind on the stove where Kiki Mori live
according to some legends I'll do the
trick
this trigga is gerelds foe and episode 3
of the series betrayer moon and the
witcher Aundrey sapkowski's very first
witcher story on Netflix is the witcher
the Strega looks like a giant humanoid
monster complete with a long dangling
umbilical cord
in polish folklore the Striga is no less
dangerous but it does work a little
differently stray guy were said to be
people born with two souls and who could
be identified by their twin hearts or
extra pairs of teeth when a baby was
born that people suspected was a stray
god they were banished then one of their
souls died and they became monsters
often with feathers and blue or gray
skin who transformed into alles to suck
the blood of their victims the Strega is
one of the most dangerous creatures in
Polish folklore and it's not easy to get
rid of them some people claim that
cutting off a Stricker's head and
burying it far away from the body will
get the job done although burying one
face down with a sickle around its neck
is said to work to the witcher's fourth
episode of banquets bastards and burials
is based on the Brothers Grimm story
Hans my hedgehog in that story a child
named Hans is born with the legs of a
human and the body and head of a
hedgehog years after his family casts
him out
Hans runs across two lost kings in the
forest Hans offers to help them find
their way but for a price
each ruler needs to give Hans the first
thing that greets the King at the royal
court upon his arrival home that ends up
being the princess meaning Hans gets a
beautiful wife for his trouble Hans and
Unni the curse night in The Witcher
dipper and a few subtle ways while
Dooney is as big as a man Hans is more
Hedgehog size he rides a rooster like a
horse and is often mistaken for an
animal further Dooney simply transforms
into a human Hans his shift is a lot
more gruesome not only does he
physically shed his Hedgehog skin but
after throwing it into the fire his new
human skin is charred black requiring
the aid of a local healer the dryads of
broeckel on forests don't mess around
forced into hiding by humans and
monsters they fearsomely protect their
land from intruders they shoot series
friend ara before he can even reach the
woods they force all newcomers to drink
the water of broke alone which kills
anyone who harbors ill will against the
forest and makes anyone who doesn't
slowly forget their past accordingly the
witcher's dryads dress an armor and
heavy makeup their imposing figures as
they should be and they resolutely stand
their ground that's a big departure from
the dryads of greek mythology where the
creatures originated in the original
myths dryads
or nymphs who are tied to forest their
trees were actually known to be
exceptionally shy they didn't really
fights although some of them could
transform from human-like creatures into
trees for the most part dryads are
passive figures in the Greek myths it
was up to the witcher to give them some
grit
don't hurt me
that's enough in rare species Geraldton
ya skier joined a group of warriors who
are competing to see who can kill a
dragon first not only is the hunt that
ensues full of twists and turns but it's
a big part of the witcher's
behind-the-scenes history the story that
the episode is based on the bounds of
reason is an adaptation of the Polish
folktale that inspired Sapkowski to
create Carrollton the first place
the story of the bevelle dragon dates
back to the 13th century and while it
takes many forms some elements are
always the same there's always a king
whose subjects are terrorized by a man
eating cattle devouring dragon there are
always brave knights who try to conquer
the dragon in hopes of winning the
princess's hand they always fail finally
there's always a hero usually depicted
as a cobbler who decides to use the
Dragons own appetite against him the
cobbler fills the sheepskin with hay and
sulfur then waits for the dragon to eat
it that makes the Dragons so thirsty
that it drinks water until it literally
explodes it's one of Poland's most
beloved stories there's even a
seven-headed statue commemorating the
dragon and Krakow butts up Kowski
thought it was ridiculous you wouldn't
call a cobbler to kill a dragon he
figured you'd call a professional and so
the author invented a fictional monster
hunter and lo and behold Geralt of Rivia
was born check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about The Witcher are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]